(audience applauds)
(upbeat jazz music)
- [Kelly Clarkson] Nice to see you!
Hi!
- [Dani Beck] Thank you.
Thank you for having us.
- [Kelly Clarkson] Aw,
thank you for coming!
(audience applauding)
- [Kelly Clarkson] So
I forget y'all probably
haven't seen each other in a minute
'cause you did this so long ago, right?
- [Ben] Straight up.
- [Kelly Clarkson] Okay I was gonna say,
I was just thinking that- y'all hugging,
I was like oh wait, y'all.
We always think it's
like y'all just did it
but obviously was done a long time ago.
- We shot it like during COVID
and so we had all been isolated
in our own homes for like months
and then we got to have
this beautiful moment
where we were all together
and getting to see each other
and spend time together.
And so now I think we all
feel that very kind of
special connection when we
(indistinct) each other.
- Well Dani, we know
you from cop shows like
Cold Case and Law and Order:
SVU, which I always say
SUV, I don't know why.
- Everybody does.
- [Kelly Clarkson] Everytime and I'm like-
- [Dani Beck] Everybody does!
what's happening.
I always say SUV and
they're like, "Not a car".
Have you- have you done a
musical like this before?
- Not quite like this, no.
But I did play Desi Arnaz
and so I had to sing.
- [Kelly Clarkson] What a cool role.
- An amazing role.
- [Kelly Clarkson] Yeah.
- Being Cuban American,
it was very personal.
- [Kelly Clarkson] Yeah!
But never quite like this.
- [Kelly Clarkson] Yeah.
Oh my God, I grew up on I love Lucy.
So, and Nick, we know you
from Atypical on Netflix,
so have you-
(crowd applauding and cheering)
- [Kelly Clarkson] I
know! It's very popular.
And it's also not a musical show.
So have you- is this new for you?
- Oh, yeah, yes.
Yeah I'm not a singer or a dancer.
- [Kelly Clarkson] So you're
going to do great. (laughs)
- They whipped me into
shape. I went through-
- Well what was it like
then singing next to-
Ben's one of literally
the best male vocalist
I've ever heard.
So like, what was it like?
And I've sung with him before.
What was it like singing with
them then, were you terrified?
- Oh my God, yeah.
Uh, well because I don't (indistinct)
they had set up private
sessions for me to,
you know, help with that and uhh
(laughter)
And during my first one with
the music director in Atlanta,
it was just supposed to
be two of us, very chill.
Ben walks in to say hello,
cause we hadn't met yet.
And he was very sweet. Hi,
how are you, all that stuff?
And the music director was like,
why don't you guys sing together?
- [Kelly Clarkson] Oh no..
- I don't know if you could
tell, but I was panicking.
- Well, you were wonderful.
And he's also wonderful in the movies.
So he's being very humble.